just to the east of kharkiv ukrainian
forces taking casualties but holding the
front line
months into this war ukraine's second
city is still holding russia back
in the centre of the city in what's left
of the council buildings the soldiers
are ukrainian
attempts by russia to take this place
and push south to the donbass region
have failed
and these images certainly present
ukraine to be winning the war here
these tell a different story filmed by
russian state tv they show russian
successes somewhere near kharkiv
as the kremlin reveals its plan for
phase two of this war take donbass and
push west maybe all the way to moldova
well then images of empty ukrainian
trenches and abandoned positions are all
part of the spin
and the word from moscow does not
suggest any sort of ceasefire is
anywhere close
as for russia ukraine talks i wouldn't
talk about platforms but about the way
ukraine treats these opportunities it's
strange for me to hear the different
kinds of statements from the ukrainian
representatives every day including the
president and his advisors which lead me
to believe that they don't need these
talks
and to make the point the violence is
reaching more and more of this country
on
island they hadn't expected the cruise
missiles two of them landed somewhere
here and locals were directing us to the
spot where one fell
right
the target intended or otherwise was a
health club for workers of the local
steel works
russia's attempt to push west would take
it through places like this
the hole from the impact is in the roof
and the shrapnel all around eight people
were injured
the other missile the mayor says landed
near this train line an evacuee train
was passing at the time the carriage
windows smashed
we'd heard the explosions as we waited
down the road for the evacuees to arrive
from the east and further south
among them people coming from places
that remind you many cities here are
under siege this time though stories
beyond the violence hints at the grind
of life under this russian occupation
they robbed them
they robbed them robbed them yes and
they robbed
watches
watches telephone and some things and
from the young man's stepfather this
remarkable story
technically
the russian army has orders to push west
to take the south to surround port
cities that is the clearly stated
intention now
but does putin's army have the
capability the last eight weeks would
suggest not
mark stone sky news in eastern ukraine
you